[Music]
has the um that that does do what we
call love legs open very easy okay legs
legs open very easy yeah i'll agree to
that legs open very easy okay okay now
two once a whole always a hoe yes or no
okay have you heard of the term what a
proverb means
i would not say that i have okay
probably means it's a statement that's
gen it's genuinely true but not always
true
that's what i would say it is okay what
about you
from my from full of i'll put it to this
way i'll give you two points from from
uh
myself
seventh when i was 17
once a whole also hell i'd probably say
i would preach that as a true statement
purely because it's a case of like
as a woman you go through like a certain
stage in your life right
i've got cheated on
so i'm gonna go do the same thing but
times ten
so i would agree with that now i would
say like
a whole i would not i would not agree
with that purely because it's like
as a woman like
you have the right to make the wrongs
right the same way a man has the right
to make wrongs right
and as a person you can look
i can have x amount of sexual partners
this is what a woman has but in our day
in society as a man
if you have x amount of partners you're
considered as a lad as a
as a player as a you know as a guy right
whereas if a woman has an x amount of
partnerships [ __ ] she's whatever
that's why it's nowadays it's like i
would seriously think about like the
woman's point of view purely for the
fact that like
as a woman if you have x amount of
partners
it's okay
because of the fact that like if you're
looking from a man's perspective
it's a bit i would say it's okay but
it's understandable yeah i think this
way you gotta be graceful at the same
time you see because
it's cause and effect yeah absolutely
it's easy this is where like i was
saying before when kevin samuel says who
taught you to be your wife but did they
have the structure to be taught how to
be a wife right and this is where we
have to have grace for both sexes both
male and females you see so well i think
you know it's like men's
like they talked about like men's they
rated like based on sexual partners men
and women's um
marital happiness and i'm pretty sure
though the highest was both had zero
okay that was that was the highest
amount well like even like yeah they
both like men and women have only slept
with each other right but on the flip
end it was like between like a guy who
said like two sexual partners and a guy
who's had eight like the guy with eight
had a higher marital satisfaction where
the women with like less
like their satisfaction dropped the more
partners they have yeah yes i think it
was like 80 like your chance of being a
happy marriage if you're a virgin is
like 80 and it drops down to like
i don't remember what it dropped out i'm
butchering this but it was like at least
at least below 50 i think it was 30 40.
well someone was a virgin
of happiness is it like so they surveyed
people i'm butchering this okay but they
surveyed people on their marital
happiness after x amount of years right
yeah and then they surveyed them on
their sexual partners okay and for men
it didn't really have like their their
number of sexual partners didn't really
have an effect
on like
like their happiness not not
significantly right and i i want to say
i think the happiest still with zero
partners for both right that's the ideal
yeah however okay however
like men's didn't really change where
women if they were not a virgin so like
if she's a virgin she has an 80 chance
of a happy marriage yes but if she's had
like two three or four this chance that
she could get highly divorced i think
i've seen that yeah and i i'm pretty
sure it when it goes from like eighty
percent and if she said five or more
it's like she's a 30 chance of a happy
marriage so it goes it drops down
significantly i was the only thing i was
gonna add to that is like and this is
i'm gonna say about a month ago that
i've seen this um
it was a case of like
um what would you rather do right so
would you rather have a person
that you know slept with a hundred men
or
would you rather have a person that you
don't know slept with like ten men but
it's hurt like you know what i mean and
i asked you that question you did that's
me
most of the guys obviously would rather
have the person that had less men yeah
but without knowing what would you do
in that situation so repeat the question
so would you rather have yeah
knowingly would you have a woman that
had slept with like over a hundred men
yes or without knowing would you rather
have a woman that slept with ten men
without knowing
wait huh um
so wait so the hunt like
he knows she has a hundred guys yeah and
then that's no body count so though it
was a hundred yeah okay well not 100 but
like just a lot a lot okay okay so one
girl's body counts a lot he knows the
second girl would you rather have a girl
that you don't know how many x amounts
you don't know you don't know but like
like 10 was the actual you know yeah i
probably wouldn't go with one i do not
know because at least i wouldn't have
that thing in my head that's exactly
that's yeah
that's what most men would go but the
problem is that if she's had so many
sexual partners the problem is that
what's the comparison and that's where a
man will become very insecure okay
if you marry someone that's um has less
one she has nothing to compare it to so
you have more chocolate problems
so next next question i have for you two
girls right and i think i've asked you
this before no way
so so you have two girls to pick from
one girl has slept with that's
let's say 25 30 guys but you don't know
any of them and you will never know them
you'll never meet them in your life they
were let's say she went to school
on the west coast okay you'll never
whatever second i love the way you're
being specific with west coast i've
heard about west coast
now second girl
she's slept with um
let's let's say five guys okay let's
but one of them
you know and you know well and you'll
always have to see him forever yeah it
was years ago yeah she
she's over she it was mutual but
you know him yeah which girl do you pick
tough one
it's a very tough one let me know in the
comments who do you pick
it's a situation with bad and worse
i'll probably go with the
person that's
caveat let's see if i'm single yeah with
the person that
probably slept with my friend but only
had five okay yeah because i'm sorry i
couldn't
probably work with that okay compared to
a hundred because it's like what's the
comparison
you know right yeah so it's about you
know it's it's choosing between two bad
options a bad option and a worse option
right yeah i'm sorry but i can't know
the thing
as a golden rule like and this is
reaching into the bro code right yeah
as a bro right uh-huh if let's say for
example um
if i have a girlfriend or not a
girlfriend but just a girl that i've
slept with right and as a bro
you've somehow managed to stumble upon
her and you slept with her and i told
you
as a bro it's kind of like for me
personally bro code wise i would i
couldn't do it what if it was what if it
was years ago it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's just broke
i'm sorry bro i just it's just bro code
broco i think like
girl it's just
girls date each other's like ex like oh
my gosh there's so many girls on the on
my team in college that like slept with
the same guy and like one of them dated
like that happened a lot but it's like
the 2080 rule right
the 20
okay next
now i'm so i'm surprised you picked the
so you would pick the girl that had the
30.
because obviously i would live by the
mentality of
if i do what you know if it's not broken
don't fix something meaning wise
before me i i know fully well that
you've obviously had a girlfriend or a
boyfriend right whatever right and
you've slept with them right that's
understand that's a god given
but
i always also live by a role of like
it's not
uh what you call it what's different
it's not
yours it's your turn okay that's what
they think and that's as cheesy as
cheesy as it sounds it's not yours it's
your turn
it's like
if i don't get married to you in that
moment in time or if i don't go and we
live a happy life after yeah someone
else will take my place the same way i
took someone else's place right off the
show right you know what i mean yeah
yeah right that's right that's the way i
especially surprised my answer because
the whole point is that what's the
chance of me parabonding with the woman
right one with less is more likely than
the one with many that's why i would
choose that option both of crap options
but you know what i heard that's the
most true thing rolo tomasi said it's
not it's not about the number it's about
the number of like alphas or like the
number of like impro whatever it's like
and because i know girls that have like
a low body count right but like that one
guy they always like want to go back too
yeah and then that one guy they always
yeah i just won no i'm going to tell you
this story so this is a girl from
people start looking up these people i'm
not going to say where i know yes
don't don't don't do it no
but
actually whatever college okay
so she went
with a guy her freshman year college
dated this man for like a month okay
super into him now this i didn't really
get it he was like five seven i'm like
you can't be tripping over yeah that's
five seven
i'm sorry no offense guys
but okay so
and like a loot like kind of a loser
like i didn't get this okay but she was
all all into this guy breaks her heart
cheats whatever
a couple years later she's dating a new
guy this man bought her a house bought
her a house okay i went to a party and i
don't this girl really didn't sleep
around that much like she was she she
didn't wasn't that big of a joke she
wasn't like you you would not you would
never never have guessed
at a party i'm there i'm in the basement
i see her while she's dating this like
the guy who bought her the house walk
out of the bathroom
with
this the guy from fresh freshman year
does that make sense so she was hooking
up with this other guy and her boyfriend
came to this party
like 45 minutes later oh and that's what
i was saying like you would never guess
but she was like the alpha alpha widow